sinking like stones apocalypse means to
destroy this world let's go to war
everything
hey youtubers it's Charlie so they drop
new footage from x-men apocalypse we get
a bunch of Psylocke they've been using
olivia munn to market the movie so let's
break it down the coolest thing is that
we see her in full comic book costume
all the characters in the movie she's
probably the closest to her comic book
depiction Olivia Munn said the Sandlot
gets to have a lot of fun in the movie
and everyone does get their powers
jacked up at least apocalypse is four
horsemen if you watch the 90s cartoon
apocalypse does put his horseman through
a special machine to give them power to
twist them to his will this is gonna be
a little bit more practical it'll
probably have something to do with his
celestial technology I know Days of
Future past was a time travel movie but
because apocalypse is one of the first
mutants obviously they're going to pay
homage to his history so a lot of that
will be dealt with in flashbacks we'll
probably get to see the pyramid him find
the ancient ship him get a celestial
armor I've talked a little bit about his
origin story in the last trailer video
that I posted so I'll put a link in the
description and I'm so happy that they
added things like Cylons I blaze that
was one of the big questions that Olivia
Munn answered early on we'll psylocke
get her psionic blades and yes they have
been teasing a Dark Phoenix storyline
with Sophie Turner's character at a
certain point I don't know how soon
they're gonna get there there's gonna be
one more x-men film that Bryan Singer is
gonna work on we don't know what that's
gonna be yet it'll depend on where they
leave things at the end of this film but
that's why they've introduced new Jean
Grey new Cyclops new storm the funny
thing that she said about new Cyclops is
that Scott Summers the young Scott
Summers kind of a douchebag and it's
just the latest in a line of people
calling Scott Summers a douchebag he's
one of the most maligned characters in
x-men comics whether you love him or
hate him most people hate him they've
been a couple good Cyclops moments they
have this really weird thing going on
with this character in the comics now I
won't spoil it but if you're a big fan
of x-men they've rebooted the comics
since Secret Wars it's actually pretty
interesting
there's a lot of inhuman related things
going on all these apocalyptic world
ending visions probably has something to
do with Jean Grey but I'm expecting a
little bit of it to go down in the movie
just because people's powers are gonna
be off the scale Magneto for instance
you see this scene here where he's
twisting all this metal he's just going
crazy and it looks like in the time
since they posted the last trailer they
polished the special effects there's so
many special effects in this film like
even apocalypse his face looks different
his voice sounds
from the last trailer like when you're
done with this just loop the trailer
part rewatch the trailer then go back
and watch the last trailer video I post
it you'll hear apocalypses voice sounds
different it's still Oscar Isaac but I
think that they changed his voice little
they did the exact same thing with Bane
during Dark Knight Rises
I guess Tom Hardy did a version of the
Bane voice when they were recording the
movie and then later Christopher Nolan
decided he didn't like it so they just
brought him in they did a completely
different voice we get some angel
Nightcrawler Thunderdome action and they
have been talking about Evan Peters
character about the Quicksilver
character I know there's a little
confusion between Marvel's Quicksilver
and Fox's Quicksilver this version of
Quicksilver will be Magneto's son they
teased it during Days of Future past hey
my mom used to go out with a guy of the
control metal I don't know how big of a
plot point it's gonna be but there's
gonna be a lot more Quicksilver in this
film he was one of the most fun parts of
Days of Future past I'm really pumped
about that I do like the new x-men armor
the new storm looks amazing she's gonna
be so much fun not really sure about
Magneto's armor I'm curious to see if
apocalypse helps adapt celestial armor
for him when he becomes a horseman and
here looks like apocalypse is turning
mystique into an afternoon snack now I
know this is a big change from the
comics because mystique has always been
a servant of apocalypse so I guess I'm
okay with them breaking from comic book
can and I think they just want her at
odds with magneto and they wanted
magneto to be one of the horsemen so
they didn't want them on the same team
we can talk about all the big changes
the movie made to the comics whenever it
drops but let me know what you think
about the idea of a future Dark Phoenix
storyline obviously that's a saga that
would take place over a number of films
I think the idea is that they're
transitioning from older actors to these
new actors so they're trying to
introduce them one at a time
and because we have x-force New Mutants
Deadpool now they're weaving this larger
universe I'm really interested to see if
they try to use Psylocke on the other
films but people actually did ask Olivia
Munn do you want to be in the x-force
film do want to be in a movie with
Deadpool of course she said the thing
that you would expect all actors to say
like everybody thinks their character is
the most important character she's like
I want to do a Psylocke solo film I'll
say right now if Marvel hasn't done a
Black Widow solo film by now there's no
way that Fox is gonna do a Psylocke solo
film they're too busy ramping up
Deadpool trying to get x-force off the
ground I think eventually we'll see a
solo x-men female lead film most of the
best Marvel female characters are part
of the X
in universe so Fox has access to all
those people that's why they originally
went after Jennifer Lawrence for
mystique but let me know in the comments
what you guys favorite Super Bowl
trailers so far there's still a couple
that I haven't got to yet there's a new
Deadpool one there's a ninja turtles one
I might do the Ninja Turtles one too
because it actually looks pretty cool so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and yes there is some new Batman V
Superman but it's not an official
trailer so we'll see I'll have to take a
look they might drop some new stuff
later tonight just in case you guys
haven't seen it you can click here for
my Captain America Civil War Super Bowl
trailer and you can click here for my
Deadpool vs. Wolverine video thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you